j'ai trouvé que c'était le moment pour
un nouveau challenge
le nouveau défi de jonathan david et
commencer à lille le jeune homme de 20
ans a été officiellement présenté à la
presse française après son acquisition
par le losc au coût de 47 millions de
dollars
son transfert est le joueur le plus cher
de l'histoire du soccer canadien est le
plus gros montant déboursé par lille
pour acquérir un nouveau membre
c'est un honneur au moins de vue à la
zorro si cher mais après ça met pas de
pression ni rien c'est géré c'est comme
ça le football et après pour moi c'est
de performer sur le terrain le franco
ontarien a déjà sauté sur le terrain
pour s'entraîner avec sa nouvelle équipe
tu avais d'espère poursuivre sur sa
lancée de la dernière année en 1re ligue
belge
il a marqué à 18 reprises pour terminer
la saison à égalité au sommet des
buteurs de ta vie aussi été nommé joueur
canadien de l'année en 2019
il a choisi la ligue 1 française plutôt
que la prestigieuse premier relais en
angleterre pour poursuivre son
développement
moi je voulais aller quelque part où je
continue à jouer à devenir meilleurs et
franchement ici j'ai un très bonne
équipe avec beaucoup de bons joueurs et
un très bon collectif c'est un joueur
spécial le losc croit avoir mis la main
sur un attaquant rapide et puissant qui
possède un flair hors du commun autour
du filet son calme et son contrôle ont
aussi retenu l'attention du directeur
général de la formation même s'il a 20
ans il démontrerait déjà quelques signes
aux quelques stats de maturité dans les
clubs et la sélection de canada j'essaie
de viser le plus haut possible alors
chemin je ne donne pas de nom me dis
juste que je vais aussi marque le plus
de buts possible pour aider l'équipe
tu habites pourrait disputer son premier
match avec sa nouvelle équipe dimanche
il tiendra le dernier match amical de sa
préparation estivale devant une foule de
5000 personnes et simbaya radio canada
ottawa